there's three really defining guiding
principles one do no harm when you find
yourself in the crisis make sure you
take no actions are going to compound
the situation and dig yourself a deeper
hole number two have discipline have a
strategy executing that strategy don't
get caught up in the fog of war and lose
your head and make basic mistakes that
cause you more problems and number three
at the end of the day the single most
important principle to survival is
maintaining your credibility ultimately
the North Star that you're looking at is
establishing or reestablishing trust
with the people that you care about the
road to trust is by demonstrating your
incredible entity who can be trusted in
terms of answering questions providing
information taking responsibility
holding themselves accountable if you
abide by those three basic principles do
no harm have a disciplined approach
credibility at the point of the realm
those are the really are three
principles are the keys to survival and
then you can take the various tactics
the tactics that we refer to as the 10
commandments of damage control and they
will help you in a step-by-step process
be able to limit the damage and pivot
and be able to move forward
you